Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
Les démons de Poutine.
Avant l'invasion de l'Ukraine,
Vladimir Poutine fut adulé
des grands de ce monde, notamment
de responsables européens,
même si son autoritarisme
faisait l'objet de critiques
et qu'il inspirait de la méfiance
pour ses manières brutales
en vue d'éliminer tout ce qui
s'opposait à son pouvoir.
Depuis février 2022
et le déferlement de l'armada
militaire russe en Ukraine,
détruisant sans discernement
les infrastructures vitales
et décimant
des populations innocentes,
c'est une tout autre appréciation
de Poutine qui est mise en exergue
par les médias
et la classe politique
qui louaient auparavant
l'autocrate du Kremlin.
On découvre
ou on feint de découvrir
sa jeunesse turbulente à Leningrad,
l'URSS à l'époque,
lorsqu'il fréquentait
la pègre de Saint-Pétersbourg,
un serviteur sinon un ordonnateur
des basses oeuvres du KGB à Dresde,
un fossoyeur des avancées libérales
de ses prédécesseurs,
Gorbatchev et Eltsine,
dès son accession
dans les cercles du pouvoir,
l'adepte d'un système de corruption
à l'intérieur de la Russie
comme au sein
des capitales européennes
éblouies par les fortunes
d'oligarques à la solde du Kremlin,
un anti-occidentalisme primaire
et un menteur invétéré.
Comment a-t-on pu
se tromper à ce point
sur le responsable
d'une des plus grandes nations
de la planète,
dotée de surcroît d'une puissance
nucléaire redoutable
qui trompa la communauté
diplomatique internationale
par ses tirades
sur l'humiliation de la Russie,
mais ne manqua jamais
d'exprimer en paroles et en actes,
je parle de Vladimir Poutine
sa puissance absolue ?
C'est ce que nous allons
chercher à comprendre
avec mes invités,
Madame Hélène Carrère
d'Encausse. Vous être historienne,
secrétaire perpétuelle
de l'Académie française.
Laure Mandeville,
vous êtes journaliste. Vous avez
été correspondante à Moscou
pour le journal Le Figaro.
Alexandre Melnik,
vous êtes ancien diplomate russe
et professeur de géopolitique.
Nerijus
Aleksiejunas, vous êtes ambassadeur
de la République
de Lituanie en France.
Une question se pose,
Poutine, on a le sentiment
qu'il est sorti
d'un trou de serrure kgbiste
pour faire carrière
d'abord à Saint-Pétersbourg,
puis au Kremlin sans qu'on sache
vraiment qui il était.
Dans la galaxie d'abord tsariste,
puis bolchévique
et après, à quelle filiation
politique appartient-il ?
Madame Carrère d'Encausse.
-Je ne dirais pas qu'il appartient
à une filiation politique,
il essaie de se rattacher
et d'emblée,
quand il est arrivé au pouvoir,
il a montré
quel était son dieu,
c'était Pierre Legrand.
Je ne sais pas s'il connaissait
très bien son histoire,
mais Pierre Legrand incarnait
pour lui la puissance, la puissance
du pays. Et je pense que
si on réfléchit à ce qui l'anime,
ce qu'il a retenu
de Pierre Legrand,
c'était l'homme
qui a édifié la puissance,
une puissance,
ce qu'a été l'empire russe
et Georges Sokoloff,
mon défunt collègue,
qui a été un grand professeur
d'économie de l'URSS
et de la Russie,
avait trouvé le qualificatif,
la puissance pauvre,
c'est-à-dire la puissance
qui s'est édifiée
au détriment du bien-être social,
au détriment du progrès
et de la modernisation.
Au fond, on peut dire
que Poutine a retenu cette idée
et pour moi, il est guidé
par la volonté de puissance,
il est convaincu
que Pierre Legrand,
par sa puissance,
a édifié un empire
immense et il regarde
de tous les côtés,
et je voudrais dire
tout de suite qu'il a réussi
un tour de force. Pierre Legrand
avait réussi une chose du point
de vue
de la puissance territoriale,
c'est installer, établir
un contrôle de la Baltique
pour un pays qui n'avait pas accès
aux mers, il avait raté ça
sur la mer Noire et il a réussi à
installer la Russie sur la Baltique
et Vladimir Poutine a réussi
à perdre le contrôle de la
Baltique, ce qui est remarquable.
-Madame Carrère d'Encausse,
vous dites qui lui s'apparente
à Pierre Legrand.
-Il s'apparente, il se réclame.
-Il se réclame, mais il se réclame
depuis quand de Pierre Legrand ?
Maintenant,
on connaît son itinéraire,
son passé, ça n'a rien à voir
avec, j'allais dire,
une grandeur de tsariste ou etc.
C'est plutôt les bas-fonds.
-Non, c'est pas son problème,
son problème, il l'a présenté
comme son modèle.
Cela dit, les bas-fonds, ça a été
un voyou de Saint-Pétersbourg.
Ca a été un gamin qui a été élevé
d'une façon manifestement,
quand on regarde sa biographie,
très libre,
il fréquentait
les voyous du quartier.
Et ensuite, très tôt, il a voulu
aller dans le KGB, il y est rentré,
véritablement
dans l'instance de sécurité
et il n'était pas inconnu,
mais il a été très tôt à l'étranger
en Allemagne
de l'Est et par conséquent,
il n'a réapparu dans son pays
que tardivement.
-C'est votre avis,
Monsieur
Aleksiejunas ? Monsieur Poutine
se réclamant de Pierre Legrand,
c'est comme ça
qu'on le voit
dans les pays baltes
et notamment en Lituanie ?
-Je pense, il est obsédé
par l'histoire, c'est vrai,
je suis d'accord avec Madame
la Secrétaire sur ce point.
Mais je pense que, pour nous,
Poutine, c'est apparatchik de KGB
avec la valeur de KGB,
avec la valeur de force,
avec la valeur des armées
et des forces de sécurité,
mais aussi, pour nous, le régime
de Poutine, le régime criminel,
parce que si nous revoyons toute
l'histoire du pouvoir du régime
de Poutine, c'était beaucoup
de crimes faits à l'époque,
beaucoup d'opposants étaient
tués, donc c'était pas
les valeurs qui étaient
créées par Poutine,
c'était toujours... cette nécessité
pour construire le système criminel
avec l'organisation du pays,
avec les oligarques,
qui sont fidèles,
pour Poutine,
pour créer cette verticale
et pour soutenir le pays.
-Pierre Legrand,
filiation criminelle,
Laure Mandeville,
au niveau de la filiation ?
-Au niveau de la filiation,
je dirais qu'il y a deux filiations
pour moi.
Poutine, en fait,
c'est le digne successeur
ou l'indigne successeur de
la tradition nationale-bolchévique,
qui est une sorte de force
d'occupation qui s'est emparée
de la Russie en 1917,
et qui, depuis,
s'accroche au pouvoir
et ne cède pas le terrain.
Nous avons cru
en fait
que ces nationaux-bolchéviques
et leur version la plus criminelle,
c'est-à-dire le KGB,
avaient cédé le terrain en 1991.
Et en réalité, des décombres
des ruines du communisme a émergé
une sorte d'animal, de dragon,
qui est à la fois le successeur,
comme je le dis,
de Lénine, de Staline,
de Dzerjinski,
mais aussi qui va puiser
dans le passé impérial,
parce qu'en réalité,
le national-bolchévisme
avait aussi embrassé la tradition
impériale russe,
donc Poutine va chercher,
il pratique
une sorte de syncrétisme
et va chercher dans la tradition
impériale russe des éléments
pour justifier
en fait la politique de revanche
et de reconquête qu'il a engagée,
mais je dirais qu'il y a aussi
un aspect profondément
criminel. Et là,
il est à la fois tchékiste,
c'est-à-dire le KGB
et la pègre en fait,
parce que
il a aussi embrassé dans les années
90... Il faut voir que Poutine,
quand il revient de Dresde
et qu'il fait son chemin
dans la Russie
postcommuniste, il va
en réalité devenir
une sorte d'homme
qui fait le lien
entre les structures de force
et le monde du crime organisé.
C'est cet homme
avec toutes ces influences
différentes qui arrive au pouvoir.
Le dernier élément,
c'est l'autocratie.
-Alexandre Melnik,
vous avez l'avantage,
si on peut dire, de connaître
la Russie de l'intérieur
et même l'URSS avant.
Vous êtes même sorti de MGIMO,
c'est-à-dire l'ENA
russe. Pour vous, c'est quoi,
les deux, trois grands traits
de la filiation politique
de Poutine ?
-Cette filiation politique
du phénomène Poutine,
il faut la rechercher
dans les profondeurs
de la continuité
de l'histoire de Russie,
qui passe par cette parenthèse
de l'Union soviétique.
Quand je dis les profondeurs
de l'histoire de la Russie,
je pourrais parler
de trois phénomènes
récurrents qui traversent
toute l'histoire de la Russie
et qui s'incarnent d'une certaine
façon dans le phénomène Poutine.
D'abord, c'est le nihilisme
juridique. La civilisation russe,
la civilisation des Slaves de l'est
de façon générale
n'avait jamais connu
de Rome, c'est-à-dire
la matrice du droit,
de la légalité.
Et donc le nihilisme juridique,
c'est le rejet viscéral
de la loi et la dominance
de la morale par rapport à la loi.
Le deuxième phénomène,
c'est le phénomène assez paradoxal
pour ce grand pays, pour le plus
grand pays du monde en termes
de taille, parce que ce pays
se sent toujours assiégé.
C'est un phénomène
de forteresse assiégée.
Comme si, autour de la Russie,
il n'y avait que des ennemis,
qui voulaient la détruire.
Ce phénomène se retrouve aussi
dans le caractère et les actions
de Poutine. Et troisième phénomène,
c'est aussi le phénomène
historique, c'est la théorie
de la troisième Rome.
La Russie ne veut pas
être comme tous les pays du monde.
La Russie veut
être différente,
la Russie veut être
la troisième Rome,
la première tombée,
la deuxième, Constantinople,
tombée sous les coups
de l'Empire ottoman.
-Il est le produit
de ces frustrations
historiques ?
-De ces frustrations historiques,
y compris évidemment
cette parenthèse soviétique
avec ce terreau nourricier
des années 90,
qui ont suivi l'effondrement
de l'Union soviétique.
-On y reviendra.
Madame Carrère d'Encausse,
on sait que Poutine a commencé
sa carrière
à Berlin-Est comme agent du KGB.
Est-ce que vous diriez qu'il est
toujours resté un kgbiste,
c'est-à-dire un peu
à la manière,
pardonnez-moi la comparaison,
des jésuites ou des trotskistes,
sans qu'il y ait
de cause à effet bien entendu,
mais est-ce que vous diriez
que finalement,
il reste toujours l'homme du KGB,
même si ça a pris
d'autres dénominations, FSB, etc. ?
-Je pense que c'est sa formation.
Une fois encore,
je reviens, l'enfance,
c'était manifestement un gamin qui
a été presque sans surveillance.
On sait qu'il était
assez voyou.
Il est entré dans le KGB, il a eu
à 16 ans la révélation
qu'il avait envie
de vivre
dans cette structure
qui avait été inventée
par Dzerjinski
au moment de la révolution.
Et incontestablement,
c'est sa formation mentale.
Il y a pas de doute, c'est-à-dire
une formation fondée...
Je reviens sur l'idée
de puissance, parce qu'on ne peut
pas la laisser de côté.
Il est convaincu que rien n'est
plus fort que la puissance,
on tient les autres.
C'est le plus fort qui l'emporte
par des méthodes
qui sont, alors là,
la formation kgbiste,
mais aussi la formation bolchévique
est une formation sans vergogne.
On évoquait tout à l'heure
la criminalité. Moi, je dirais
les gens qui passent
par la fenêtre d'une façon
inopinée, il n'y a qu'à regarder
l'histoire soviétique,
elle en est pleine.
Enfin, de Trotski qu'on est allé
assassiner loin,
même la femme de Lénine.
Elle est morte
d'une façon très suspecte.
Justement, le principe,
c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de respect de la vie humaine,
il y a le pouvoir, la puissance,
il y a d'un côté le pouvoir
et le reste qui doit suivre.
Incontestablement,
il est resté, je dirais,
le produit de cette éducation,
et je voudrais tout de suite
poser une question.
Le produit d'une éducation,
toute entière fondée
sur l'idée que l'instance qui tient
tout le pays, qui tient
tous les renseignements,
sur tout et sur tout le monde,
que ça donne un homme qui s'engage
dans une guerre pas renseigné
ne sachant pas ni l'état du pays,
ni l'état du pays où il va, etc.,
c'est pour moi
le plus grand mystère.
Je ne comprends pas
que l'homme du KGB,
quand j'entends dire : "Attendez,
"on ne l'a pas renseigné
ou on l'a mal renseigné."
C'est complètement absurde !
Un homme qui a passé sa vie
dans cette instance, qui sait
à quel point
le renseignement est fondamental,
il faut se méfier des autres,
à quel point
on doit tenir tout le monde,
se retrouve mal renseigné,
ne sachant pas,
croyant que l'Ukraine
n'existe pas, qu'on peut envoyer
des armées pas préparées
dans un pays qui a été préparé,
c'est ahurissant !
-On va...
-Je voulais souligner qu'on ne peut
pas dire, c'est l'homme du KGB,
sans s'étonner, je dirais, de son
incompétence comme homme du KGB.
-Est-ce que historiquement,
si quelqu'un veut répondre
à cette question, quand il était
au KGB à Berlin-Est, il a...
-A Dresde.
-Pardonnez-moi.
Est-ce que, quand il était
donc en RDA à l'époque,
il a commis des actions criminelles
à l'égard des pays occidentaux ?
Laure Mandeville.
-En fait,
les choses commencent à sortir
sur cette période, qui a été
soigneusement,
si vous voulez, expurgée,
de toutes les biographies
officielles de Poutine
et ceux qui se penchaient
sur cette question
le faisaient
avec beaucoup de précautions,
parce que c'était un sujet
extrêmement sensible,
mais vous avez notamment
le livre de Catherine Belton, dont
je vois que vous avez un exemplaire
à côté de vous, "Les hommes de
Poutine", qui a livré une enquête
extrêmement intéressante
et extrêmement poussée
justement du parcours de Poutine
et de ses années à Dresde.
Ce qu'elle dit, c'est que,
contrairement à ce que Poutine
a voulu faire croire en laissant
entendre qu'il n'avait un rôle
absolument, quasiment inexistant
et totalement marginal
à Dresde,
il était impliqué
en fait dans, d'abord,
les opérations
en interaction avec la Stasi,
puisqu'il avait toute une équipe
de la Stasi avec laquelle
il travaillait pour recruter
des espions à l'Ouest.
Et aussi, dit-elle, en tout cas,
c'est une hypothèse qu'elle émet,
par exemple,
en allant voir un ancien
de la fraction Armée rouge,
j'ai trouvé cela incroyable,
qu'elle ait sorti ça,
un ancien
de la fraction Armée rouge,
qui étaient ces réseaux
terroristes allemands
qui ont commis des attentats
en Europe occidentale,
elle explique que Poutine, d'après
cet homme qui en faisait partie,
faisait partie,
s'occupait de superviser
certaines opérations
de la fraction Armée rouge.
Pour répondre à votre question,
c'est un élément qui montre
qu'il était en première ligne
pour des opérations
extrêmement sensibles
directement dirigées
contre l'Occident.
-Votre avis,
Alexandre Melnik ?
-Pour vous répondre,
je vais convoquer mon expérience,
mon passé d'ancien diplomate
soviétique et russe.
J'ai commencé ma carrière
à l'ambassade de Paris
dans ce fameux bunker
boulevard Lannes en 1981.
-Vous avez résidé
dans l'ambassade...
-J'habitais
rue de Grenelle.
-La résidence.
-De l'ambassadeur de Russie.
Mais il faut remonter un peu
à la source et la source, d'abord,
c'est d'où il vient, Poutine. Comme
disait Madame Carrère d'Encausse,
c'était quelqu'un qui était
formé, formaté par la rue.
C'était quelqu'un
qui n'appartenait pas
à ce qu'on appelait
la nomenklatura soviétique.
Et il gardait toujours
cette frustration finalement,
cette espèce de revanche,
de vengeance par rapport
à sa situation initiale.
Il n'a pas fait le MGIMO,
contrairement à moi. Le MGIMO,
c'était l'ENA, HEC réunis.
Il a fait la fac de droit
dans le pays du nihilisme
juridique. C'est quoi la fac
de droit ? Qui ne menait à rien,
cette fac de droit,
mais il a compris tout de suite
que l'ascenseur social
dans ce pays
à cette époque historique,
c'est le KGB. Il a toqué
à la porte du représentant du KGB.
D'ailleurs, il y avait toujours
des représentants
dans les universités
de l'Union soviétique. Il a dit :
je veux travailler avec vous.
On lui a dit, tu
finis tes études et on verra.
Après, il a été engagé
par le KGB. Il ne voulait pas
travailler pour le KGB intérieur.
Parce que c'est plutôt
la délation, etc. Il voulait
toujours être un espion.
Mais avait-il vraiment
les aptitudes pour être un vrai
espion ? La question reste ouverte.
Il était nommé où ? Il était nommé
à Dresde.
-Pas tout de suite.
Il a d'abord fait des opérations
de surveillance
de la population à l'intérieur.
-Le lien
que vous faites entre KGB
et industrie du crime.
-Industrie du crime, ce que je veux
dire par là,
c'est que c'était plutôt
un lieutenant,
un exécutant des basses oeuvres,
mais des basses oeuvres
sans grande importance.
Il travaillait à Dresde, où ?
A la représentation commerciale.
Il n'avait même pas
de passeport diplomatique.
Dresde n'est pas la capitale.
Donc son poste était
relativement subalterne.
Il travaillait plutôt...
-C'est contesté, ça,
par Belton, par exemple.
-C'était
la collecte des informations,
qui lui permettait
d'être au contact
des Allemands, non seulement
des Allemands de l'Est, mais aussi
de l'Ouest,
qui commençaient d'ailleurs un peu
à s'intéresser à ce marché,
par exemple, Siemens,
et d'autres grandes compagnies.
Cela lui a permis
de peaufiner son allemand,
d'être en contact
avec ces interlocuteurs
appartenant à un autre monde,
à un autre univers
intellectuel,
aussi essayer de prendre
l'ascendant moral,
psychologique sur eux,
mais je n'exagérerai jamais le rôle
de Poutine dans cette industrie
du crime que vous évoquez.
C'était plutôt quelqu'un
qui voulait faire des choses,
mais qui n'avait pas énormément
d'importance alors.
-Monsieur l'ambassadeur,
je voudrais vous poser
une question.
Zbigniew Brzezinski
considère que, sans l'Ukraine,
la Russie ne peut pas être
une puissance impériale.
Est-ce que vous partagez, vous,
cet avis historique ?
-Non, je pense, pour nous,
c'est un peu difficile
pour comprendre pourquoi,
parce que...
Parce que la Russie
est un grand pays,
comme nous avons commencé
notre discussion.
C'est un grand territoire,
avec beaucoup de gens,
avec beaucoup de ressources
naturelles. Pourquoi il faut
faire une invasion
pour les autres pays.
Donc la Russie est un grand pays.
Pour nous, c'est un peu
peut-être une des erreurs
que nous avons faites
comme l'Europe,
que nous avons pensé
qu'on peut comprendre
la Russie et Poutine
dans notre propre rationalité.
Mais rationalité de Poutine
un peu différente.
Et donc c'est juste justification
parfois pour moi cette explication
que l'Ukraine est nécessaire
pour la Russie
devenir le grand pays puissant.
Parce que, pour Poutine
et pour le régime de Poutine,
les valeurs
sont différentes,
comme nous en discutions,
un peu de criminalité,
un peu de formation de KGB.
C'est différent.
C'est pourquoi c'est un peu
difficile d'expliquer pourquoi
Poutine a fait cette invasion,
on pense
dans notre propre rationalité
différente de celle de Poutine.
-Ca n'a pas de sens,
cette vision de Brzezinski,
Hélène Carrère d'Encausse ?
Parce que
vous dites qu'il est nourri
de cette pulsion impériale.
-Je l'ai souvent entendu dire ça et
il le disait bien avant, je dirais,
même avant 90, hein,
ce qu'il a voulu dire par là,
c'est que,
dans la mythologie russe,
l'Ukraine, c'est Kiev,
c'est le baptême, etc. Il y avait
la volonté de se rattacher
à toute une histoire légendaire.
C'est ça,
le problème.
Et c'est à partir de là, c'est pas
géopolitiquement, géopolitiquement,
c'est en effet
le pont vers l'Europe,
c'est très bien,
mais c'était fondamentalement,
dans la pensée,
dans la vision,
dans la conception russe,
c'est la troisième Rome,
c'est absolument nécessaire
à la Russie.
Il avait pas seulement dit ça,
il avait dit,
après 1990,
pour affaiblir la Russie,
c'est en Ukraine
qu'il faut mettre le levier.
Il l'avait dit clairement
dans "Le grand échiquier".
-Il me semble quand même que,
quand Brzezinski a parlé, il a dit,
précisément,
quand il a parlé de ce sujet,
si la Russie perd l'Ukraine,
alors, la Russie perd l'empire
et si elle perd l'empire,
alors la Russie
pourra devenir un Etat-nation.
En fait, l'un des gros problèmes
auxquels on se heurte aujourd'hui
est que la Russie se pense
encore comme un empire.
Nous ne savons même pas,
quand vous écoutez, par exemple,
beaucoup de penseurs russes,
ils vous diront
nous ne savons pas
si la Russie peut devenir
un Etat-nation. Elle s'est conçue
comme une puissance
expansionniste, c'est ce que
disait Alexandre, c'est
à la fois le nihilisme juridique,
mais c'est aussi l'expansionnisme.
La Moscovie, en fait, qui est
le véritable moment
où la Russie se constitue
en tant que pays,
c'est une puissance
expansionniste. Et donc,
la question de l'Ukraine,
c'est le coeur.
Pourquoi, par exemple,
Staline engage
cette terrible politique
de répression atroce en Ukraine
avec l'Holodomor, etc.
?
Parce qu'il sait très bien
que c'est le coeur,
ils ne peuvent pas
se permettre de laisser
une Ukraine qui déjà en 1917,
1918, 1920, veut partir.
Ils ne peuvent pas
la laisser partir,
parce qu'à ce moment-là,
comme le dit
Mme Carrère d'Encausse,
ils perdent ce qui est
le mythe de la Russie
et donc ils perdent,
disons, leur socle
de départ. Et je pense
que c'est absolument clé.
C'est un peu
comme la question de la Serbie
avec la Yougoslavie.
A partir du moment
où la Croatie s'en allait,
la Serbie... C'était le moment
où on pouvait rompre avec l'empire,
avec la dimension
de conquête.
Et c'est absolument fondamental
pour la Russie aujourd'hui
pour mettre un terme
à cette tentation impériale.
-On va rentrer
dans le détail.
Sur le plan militaire,
avant d'engager l'invasion
de l'Ukraine, Poutine
et son armée sont intervenus
en Tchétchénie,
en Géorgie, en Syrie,
annexé la Crimée, et à chaque fois
avec une violence inouïe
et ces interventions militaires
ne sont pas exhaustives.
Cela n'a pas
empêché les grandes capitales
européennes et leurs dirigeants
de faire montre, pour le moins,
de pusillanimité.
Que pensez-vous finalement
de cet aveuglement politique ?
Parce qu'il n'a pas débarqué
en Ukraine,
alors qu'il était un archange
paisible. Tout ça s'est fait,
il y a eu beaucoup
de conquêtes militaires.
Monsieur l'ambassadeur ?
-Je pense que nous avons fait
deux erreurs fondamentales
dans le passé.
La première erreur était
que nous pensons
que peut-être si nous commerçons
avec la Russie,
on va éviter la guerre,
on va faire la dépendance
de la Russie vers l'Europe.
Le résultat était contraire.
L'Europe devient dépendante
de la Russie, comme avec Allemands,
cette dépendance énergétique,
c'est le résultat de ce lien
commercial, lien économique.
-Oui, mais est-ce qu'aux pays
baltes, on a cru que Poutine
allait devenir
ce dirigeant démocrate
à la suite de Gorbatchev ?
Ou, vous-mêmes, il y a eu
une myopie politique
dans les pays baltes
à l'égard de Poutine ?
Parce qu'il a montré
sa vraie face dès le début.
-Oui, pour nous,
c'était très clair
qu'il y a
beaucoup de menaces de ce régime.
Notre politique était
très cohérente dès le début.
Il n'y avait aucune naïveté
avec le régime de Poutine.
Peut-être la dernière fois
que notre président a rencontré
M. Poutine, c'était 2010.
C'était un ancien président de la
Lituanie et, pendant cette réunion,
nous avons reçu la liste des choses
que l'on doit faire. Je pense
que nous avons fait des choses
différentes, comme
ne pas construire le terminal GNL.
Si nous avions construit
un terminal GNL, nous serions
le premier pays d'Europe à qui
le gaz, le pétrole et l'électricité
russes auraient été coupés.
Nous avons investi
dans notre indépendance.
Cette erreur fondamentale était
que nous avons pensé que,
si on discute avec la Russie,
on peut changer Poutine
ou on peut changer
la Russie. Mais le résultat
était totalement contraire.
Totalement contraire,
parce que la Russie a commencé
à changer notre société.
C'est Poutine qui a investi
beaucoup sur la force navale,
sur la propaganda,
sur la désinformation,
sur faire une intervention
sur le processus
démocratique électoral.
C'était totalement
des résultats différents.
-Mais alors,
Laure Mandeville, sans faire
un cours de sciences politiques,
la France,
l'Allemagne, l'Italie,
pendant la dernière
décennie et même avant, ont dit
que Poutine allait sur le droit
chemin, même le président
américain Obama, en disant
que, voilà, il fallait arrimer
cette Russie poutinienne
aux démocraties,
parce que c'était un chemin.
Et pourtant,
on s'aperçoit que militairement,
on va voir après
le volant intérieur, il n'a jamais
cessé ses interventions
militaires.
Comment vous expliquez ça ?
-Je l'explique
par une sorte d'auto-aveuglement,
qui a mené
à un désastre stratégique.
Pourtant, les choses étaient
claires depuis le début.
Moi, je suis à Moscou au moment
où Vladimir Poutine arrive
au pouvoir en 99,
j'ai assisté au péché originel
de l'arrivée
de Vladimir Poutine au pouvoir,
puisqu'il arrive sur des attentats
terroristes au coeur
de Moscou, qui vont faire exploser
des citoyens russes,
dont plus personne ne doute
du fait qu'ils ont été
organisés par...
-Les services secrets.
-Pour permettre l'arrivée
au pouvoir de Vladimir Poutine
et le déclenchement
de la guerre de reconquête
en Tchétchénie,
qui lui a fait un habit de lumière
et lui a permis
de passer
d'un pourcentage de 3 ou 4
de soutien dans la population
à une majorité absolue.
Et on a vu avec mes confrères,
je n'ai pas du tout été la seule,
nous avons vu
à partir de ce moment-là
l'écrasement se mettre en route
non seulement de la Tchétchénie,
qui a été absolument atroce.
Tout le monde est horrifié
par ce qui se passe en Ukraine,
mais c'est exactement
pareil en Tchétchénie
avec des exactions,
des camps de filtration,
des horreurs à répétition,
des centaines
de milliers de morts. Et ensuite,
dans ces ruines fumantes,
nous avons vu un pouvoir
qui s'est mis, en réalité,
à reconquérir
tous les pouvoirs en Russie.
C'est-à-dire toutes...
Les choses avaient commencé, déjà,
à se déglinguer
et à se gâter
pendant la période eltisienne
qui n'est pas dénuée de problèmes.
Il y a eu le bombardement
en plein coeur de Moscou,
la première guerre de Tchétchénie,
les élections de 96
qui ont été manipulées
pour permettre
à Eltsine de rester au pouvoir.
Beaucoup de choses
qui clochaient.
Mais Poutine s'est mis à nettoyer
complètement
la scène politique et ensuite,
il est parti à l'extérieur.
Il y a eu une reconquête intérieure
de tous les leviers
et les contrepouvoirs en Russie,
du Parlement,
des médias,
de l'oligarchie en 2003
avec Khodorkovski
qui est jeté en prison. Et donc,
c'est l'effondrement de toute forme
de vrai pouvoir économique.
A partir de là, en 2004,
il essaie de reprendre
en main l'Ukraine,
mais l'Occident ferme les yeux.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il s'accroche à l'idée
que Poutine, quand même,
va remettre de l'ordre.
Oui, c'est de l'autoritarisme,
mais on peut faire avec lui.
On fait du commerce,
certains gagnent de l'argent,
il y a des gens
qui sont achetés, etc.
Il y a donc plein de ressorts
qui font que...
Des gens crient dans le désert,
disent que ça va déborder,
mais personne ne fait rien.
Pour revenir à la question
de Mme Carrère d'Encausse,
à savoir pourquoi, Vladimir Poutine,
qui était un tchékiste,
s'est trompé ? Mais en fait,
pour une raison très simple.
C'est parce qu'il n'y a plus
aucun garde-fou ni à l'intérieur
ni à l'extérieur.
L'Occident s'étant couché
devant tous les dérapages,
devant toutes les dérives,
l'invasion de la Géorgie...
-On vous a entendue.
-Mais c'est important.
Je veux dire que dans
la personnalité de Poutine,
il y a le substrat dont on a parlé,
le KGB, le voyou, etc.
Mais il y a aussi
l'homme qui, à un moment,
a l'ivresse de la puissance.
-Pardonnez-moi, Laure Mandeville,
les médias ont aussi leur part,
car ils ont encensé Poutine.
-Pas tous.
-Oui, mais enfin...
-Je suis désolée.
-On a laissé faire.
-Pas tout le monde.
-Votre analyse, M. Melnik.
Tant sur le plan intérieur
que sur le plan extérieur,
Poutine a montré sa vraie face
dès le début et même avant
d'arriver au Kremlin.
-Bien sûr.
Le régime de Poutine
a porté la guerre
et toutes les atrocités
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui,
comme, pour reprendre
l'expression de Jaurès,
"la nuée portait l'orage".
C'était évident dès le début.
Mais pour réaliser ça,
il faut connaître la Russie.
Votre question "Pourquoi
l'Occident se trompe
toujours sur la Russie ?",
c'est une question éminemment
philosophique. Je pense que
le logiciel mental occidental
tombe en panne quand on parle
de la Russie, de façon générale.
On voit la Russie
dans la continuité immuable
en faisant abstraction
des régimes politiques qui changent,
comme si la Russie était toujours
la continuité des tsars,
des soviets...
On ne comprend pas très bien,
mais enfin, le chaos et l'anarchie
postsoviétiques, etc.,
alors que nous extrapolons
sur la Russie
notre propre rationalité.
Comme si c'était "Le discours
de la méthode" de Descartes
que vous essayez de lire
dans un asile de fous.
L'âme slave
est tellement compliquée à détecter,
à déceler, alors que nous,
nous extrapolons
nos propres critères,
nos propres frustrations,
sur la Russie
que nous ne comprenons pas.
Autant nous comprenons
les Etats-Unis
avec l'ancien mécanisme
qui peut tarauder
la société française, autant
nous ne comprenons pas la Russie,
mais nous aimons,
généralement, la Russie,
comme si elle représentait
l'alternative par rapport à nous.
Donc, la Russie,
dans cette vision française,
de façon holistique générale,
entre, je dirais,
de façon un peu grossière,
entre Tchaïkovski,
Dostoïevski, kalachnikovs et vodka.
Donc, il faut,
à un moment donné, passer
à une vraie vision de la Russie
qui tient compte
du changement de régime.
Le régime des tsars
n'est pas le régime des soviets.
Le régime d'Eltsine n'est pas
le régime de Poutine.
Donc, pourquoi, nous,
nous pouvons déceler les régimes
politiques des autres pays du monde,
alors que notre logiciel mental
tombe en panne
quand il s'agit de la Russie ?
-Mme Carrère d'Encausse,
je vais faire
une comparaison historique
qui n'est pas tout à fait exacte,
mais pour comprendre les choses.
Si on prend l'événement
et l'avènement du nazisme,
on voit comment Hitler
conquiert le pouvoir.
Il y a la nuit de Cristal,
les mesures anti-juives,
il y a l'aristocratie
qui adhère,
puis la Wehrmacht, etc.
Quand on prend l'histoire
de Poutine, même si les choses
ne sont pas similaires,
on s'aperçoit
que sur le plan militaire
comme sur le plan intérieur,
Mme Mandeville en a parlé,
il a mis à bas à la justice,
il a mis à bas
les libertés de Gorbatchev,
il a mis à bas les oligarques
qui étaient pour
une ouverture en Occident,
il s'est attaqué à tous ses voisins,
il a considéré que le proche
étranger, c'était chez lui, etc.
Comment vous expliquez
que malgré tout,
l'Europe, même les Etats-Unis,
sont là,
dans un attentisme
et en espérant quoi ?
-Attendez.
Je crois qu'il ne faut pas
bousculer le calendrier.
Quand Poutine arrive,
c'est la fin de l'année 1999,
à l'issue de 10 années
de chaos en Russie,
un chaos qui était inéluctable.
En effet, le démantèlement
du système soviétique,
après 75 ans,
c'était une affaire
extraordinairement compliquée.
Je me souviens de Jeffrey Sachs
m'expliquant à moi,
le charmant jeune homme de Chicago,
combien l'expérience
était intéressante.
-Il s'est trompé ?
-Oui.
Non, mais ce que je veux dire,
ça montre là aussi l'aveuglement.
L'idée que c'était une expérience.
L'expérience a été désastreuse
parce que c'était très compliqué,
ça a ajouté au chaos.
L'Occident a vu, déjà,
avec une certaine terreur, ce chaos.
N'oubliez pas, les Etats-Unis,
c'est ailleurs. Mais la Russie,
c'est en Europe.
C'est tout de même sur
notre continent. C'est un pays
avec lequel on voisine.
Et on ne va pas le prendre
pour aller le mettre
de l'autre côté en Asie.
Il y a déjà eu cette espèce
de désarroi devant
les années Elstine. En plus,
nous avons eu des critères simples.
On s'est dit :
"Cet ivrogne fait n'importe quoi,
"a introduit un désordre formidable,
"des types ont fait fortune,
on ne comprend rien."
Et on a vu
avec un certain soulagement
un type qui sortait
on ne sait pas d'où,
car personne ne le connaissait.
Il y a eu une succession
de Premiers ministres.
Elstine les a essayés avec l'idée
qu'un d'eux pourrait lui succéder.
Et puis ça ne marchait plus,
il était très malade
et il s'est rattrapé
avec ce dernier qui était Poutine.
Il y a eu un soulagement.
On s'est dit : "L'ordre revient
"dans ce pays."
Et Poutine a su,
dès le début, se poser
en champion de l'ordre.
La seconde chose
sur laquelle je veux insister,
c'est que même
s'il n'est pas un génie politique,
il a été adroit
pendant une période.
Notamment quand il voulait faire
une opération extérieure,
il s'arrangeait
pour pouvoir la justifier
et avoir une raison
de se précipiter. Sa première
opération extérieure...
Je ne parle pas de la Tchétchénie.
C'est une affaire interne
qui fait très peur,
mais n'oubliez pas, il y a eu 2001
avec les attentats
aux Etats-Unis, etc.
Déjà, l'islam devient quelque chose
d'un peu inquiétant
pour les Européens.
On se rend compte
qu'un problème se pose à nous.
Donc, on s'est dit :
"Il règle ses problèmes là-bas."
Mais quand il est allé
en Géorgie en 2008,
il n'y est pas allé
comme en Ukraine.
Il a attendu l'occasion,
Saakachvili lui a donné un prétexte
et il y est allé.
On a dit : "Bon, ben..."
Quand il s'est emparé
de la Crimée en 2014,
c'est pareil,
il a sauté sur un prétexte,
sur les dispositions linguistiques,
de l'Ukraine.
Et du même coup,
personne n'a bougé.
Maintenant, il y va
sans prendre de précautions.
Et c'est un changement
de comportement qui est intéressant
qui explique
que tout d'un coup, on a dit :
"C'est curieux,
pourquoi est-il allé là ?"
Il n'y avait pas de raison.
Ce que je veux dire par là,
c'est qu'il y a
un comportement chez lui
qui évolue,
une espèce de prudence qui a évolué
progressivement.
La Syrie, ne l'oubliez pas.
Le problème du terrorisme,
Daesh, il a joué là-dessus.
Il a joué, tout de même,
sur le fait
que l'Occident se battait
contre le terrorisme islamiste
et qu'après tout,
en soutenant Bachar,
il soutenait le type
qui prétendait casser ça.
Je pense qu'on ne fait pas
assez attention
à cette... Je ne dis pas
que c'est une évolution
de la personnalité,
je n'en sais rien.
C'est une des questions
que je me pose.
-Si vous permettez,
je voudrais avoir votre avis.
Est-ce que dans les pays baltes,
on considère
que le Kremlin, aujourd'hui,
est une mafia criminelle ?
-Bien sûr.
Il y a toutes les preuves,
toutes les atrocités
qui ont été faites
par ce régime.
C'est notre Parlement
qui a fait une déclaration publique
sur le régime de Poutine
comme un régime criminel
et terroriste, etc.
Donc, c'est fait
par nos politiciens.
Mais je pense que ce sont nos
erreurs sur la Géorgie et la Crimée
qui ont permis
d'encourager Poutine à continuer.
Qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé,
après la Géorgie ?
Rien, nous sommes revenus
sur le business "as usual"
rapidement,
sans aucune conséquence
pour Poutine. Après la Crimée,
l'occupation du Donbass,
il y a eu les sanctions
un peu théoriques,
pas des choses très importantes,
pour Poutine.
Pour lui, c'était un message
très clair qu'il pouvait continuer.
Il n'y a eu aucune résistance,
aucune réaction
très importante de notre côté,
de l'Occident.
Ca a encouragé Poutine à continuer.
-Est-ce que vous, en Lituanie,
vous avez armé, réarmé,
parce que vous craigniez
une intervention militaire ?
-Oui. Je pense
qu'après la Crimée,
après le Donbass,
il y a eu un grand changement
dans notre politique
sur le financement de l'armée.
Maintenant, c'est plus
de 2,5 pour 100 de notre PIB
qui est dédié à la défense.
Nous avons changé cela rapidement,
nous avons investi
pour avoir la présence de l'OTAN,
pour avoir les missions
de l'OTAN chez nous,
dans notre région.
Nous avons aussi beaucoup investi
sur la cybersécurité,
sur la résilience de notre société.
-Etes-vous inquiet aujourd'hui ?
-Bien sûr,
tout le monde est inquiet.
-Selon vous, Poutine peut
intervenir dans les pays baltes ?
-Pas maintenant,
mais s'il gagne en Ukraine,
bien sûr qu'il va continuer.
Pour lui, ce sera un nouveau
message qu'il peut continuer,
que personne ne peut l'arrêter.
-Laure Mandeville ?
-En fait,
pour aller à la fois
dans le sens de ce que dit
Hélène Carrère d'Encausse
et monsieur l'ambassadeur,
c'est qu'effectivement,
il s'est enhardi.
C'est-à-dire que l'ADN est là,
sa vision du monde,
son mode de comportement,
son mépris
à la fois de la loi,
de l'homme,
des autres pays,
sa logique de puissance,
de contrôle, de soumission,
elle existe dès le départ.
C'est comme ça
qu'il a été formaté.
Mais cet homme, au départ,
est assez timide. Il regarde
comme l'Occident se comporte.
Il ne faut pas oublier
qu'il sort de nulle part,
qu'il n'a jamais eu...
Par exemple,
il n'a pas fait son chemin
dans la politique publique.
Quand il se retrouve au Kremlin,
au départ,
il est assez prudent
avec les Occidentaux.
Il est flatté,
il veut être reçu au G7, au G8.
Et d'ailleurs,
contrairement à ce qu'ont raconté
tous ceux qui disaient qu'on n'était
pas assez sympas avec lui
et que c'est pour ça
qu'il a été énervé,
il a été au contraire reçu partout,
embrassé par l'Occident.
Ce qui s'est passé, c'est que,
peu à peu, il a pris conscience
que les Occidentaux
étaient pusillanimes,
comme vous dites,
qu'ils étaient lâches et faibles.
Et en fait,
c'est cette politique d'apaisement,
cette politique de faiblesse,
qui a créé le Poutine
qu'on a aujourd'hui,
c'est-à-dire un Poutine
qui fonctionne sans garde-fou.
-Laissez-moi avoir une précision...
-Une ivresse.
Il y a une ivresse,
aujourd'hui, du pouvoir.
C'est une autocratie
dans une sorte de psychose aiguë.
-Alexandre Melnik,
il y a un point que je voudrais
préciser avec vous.
Vous avez été diplomate.
Vous connaissez la Russie,
vous êtes Russe,
enfin, vous l'étiez.
-Mon nom, Melnik,
est complètement ukrainien.
-Bon.
La question que
je voudrais vous poser,
à votre avis,
en tant qu'ex-diplomate,
si vous remettez cette casquette.
On dit qu'au début,
il était timide, il a voulu
tromper les Occidentaux, etc.
Mais ne pensez-vous pas
qu'au regard
de ce qu'il a fait
sur le plan extérieur
comme sur le plan intérieur,
il avait la stratégie
d'un dictateur, dès le départ ?
-Je ne dirais pas
la stratégie d'un dictateur.
Je dirais que
son logiciel mental n'a pas changé,
c'est celui de quelqu'un qui
est né bercé par la guerre froide.
-Mais un voyou
de Saint-Pétersbourg
qui devient président de la Russie,
c'est quand même
un formidable trajet.
Est-il venu avec
une stratégie de pouvoir ?
-Non, il n'a pas d'idéologie
ni de stratégie.
C'est quelqu'un qui se révèle
au gré des événements qui changent.
Ca, c'est vrai.
Il a une certaine
capacité d'adaptation.
Mais je dirais
que son logiciel mental,
fondamentalement,
c'est celui d'un enfant
de la guerre froide.
La guerre froide,
c'était la dépolarité du monde
avec, d'un côté,
l'Union soviétique
et de l'autre, les USA.
Il y a le communisme
et le capitalisme.
Le schéma mental de Poutine
est resté coincé à cette période.
Là-dessus,
il n'a pas évolué du tout.
Il a profité de cette situation
qui changeait, de ces années 90
que nous avons déjà évoquées,
le chaos.
Il aurait ressenti l'humiliation
du peuple russe.
Je dis bien "ressenti",
car pour moi, ce n'était pas
une vraie humiliation.
Il s'est positionné comme réparateur
de cette humiliation nationale,
un peu comme
un autre personnage historique
dont, peut-être,
je ne prononcerai pas le nom,
qui lui aussi,
s'est nourri de l'humiliation
du traité de Versailles.
Donc, sa démarche
était celle de quelqu'un
qui répare l'humiliation
et aussi... Je termine là-dessus.
Pourquoi son logiciel mental
d'un enfant de la guerre froide
n'a-t-il pas changé ?
Parce que, comme disait Laure,
il s'infiltre dans les interstices
de la faiblesse occidentale.
D'ailleurs, dès qu'il y a une
possibilité de frapper, il frappe.
Tout simplement parce que souvent,
nous sommes myopes,
pour reprendre votre expression.
Nous sommes souvent lâches
et toujours en retard alors que lui,
il anticipe toujours.
Comme disait Laure aussi,
il n'a ni garde-fou ni limites.
Alors que nous,
nous en avons beaucoup.
Nous nous sommes imposé
une ligne rouge,
nous respectons la loi,
alors que lui,
il n'a rien à respecter.
C'est quelqu'un qui se déchaîne
dans la réalisation
de ses fantasmes
et de sa vision du monde.
-Merci, Alexandre.
Percussions
...
On va essayer d'aborder
l'avenir.
Parce que l'avenir,
c'est quand même...
...un jour, la fin de cette guerre.
Comment vous l'imaginez,
Hélène Carrère d'Encausse ?
Vers quelle évolution ?
Est-ce que ce seront
des hommes comme
Kadyrov, Prigojine,
Patrouchev,
tous ces gens
qui l'entourent, les siloviki,
les services secrets, etc.,
Est-ce que c'est eux
qui vont prendre la suite
ou est-ce que vous voyez
quelque chose de plus apaisé
au regard du chaos actuel ?
-Je préfère laisser les autres
parler parce que je n'imagine pas.
-Mais vous êtes plutôt
pessimiste ou optimiste ?
-Ni l'un ni l'autre.
Je n'arrive pas à imaginer,
je pense que tout est possible,
qu'on peut avoir, je dirais,
sauf une révolution
en Russie du type 1917,
je ne crois pas qu'on ait ça,
mais que quelque chose
se produise
au niveau du pouvoir,
ça, ça me paraît
plausible, à un moment donné.
Mais qui peut le faire ?
Je ne sais pas.
Je préfère écouter
Alexandre Melnik.
-Sur ce point-là,
car la guerre finira bien un jour.
Même si elle dure encore
un certain temps.
-A court terme,
c'est la défaite militaire
du régime de Poutine qui s'impose.
C'est-à-dire que l'Ukraine
doit gagner cette guerre.
-Ce n'est pas une prévision.
-De façon écrasante
et avec l'aide
et le soutien des Occidentaux,
beaucoup plus massif et radical
que celui qui existe aujourd'hui.
Car finalement,
l'Ukraine se bat pour sa liberté,
pour sa démocratie,
mais elle se bat aussi
pour notre démocratie.
Si on laisse Poutine gagner
cette guerre, c'est l'Occident,
en tant que civilisation,
qui pourrait sortir de l'histoire.
C'est le 1er point.
La chute du régime de Poutine,
pour moi,
ça ne veut pas dire
la chute de la Russie.
Surtout, c'est le début
de la libération de la Russie.
Dans l'histoire de la Russie,
il y a toujours eu ces tendances
entre slavophiles et Occidentaux.
Il y a toujours
eu ce retour de balancier.
Moi, je pense qu'après
la défaite militaire de la Russie
et, je le répète,
pas que de la Russie,
mais du régime apolitique
de la Russie,
ce sont les nouvelles générations
russes que je connais bien,
parce que j'enseigne.
-Alors...
Pour avoir des réponses
plus précises.
Les crimes de guerre
en Ukraine sont là.
Mais auparavant,
il y avait les empoisonnements,
les assassinats,
Anna Politkovskaïa,
Alexander Litvinenko,
Skripal, Alexei Navalny,
Iouchtchenko, Saakachvili, etc.
Bon.
A votre avis,
est-ce que vous seriez favorables
à ce que les responsables
et au premier chef,
Vladimir Poutine,
soient jugés
par un tribunal international ?
Et est-ce que ce serait la condition
pour l'émergence
d'une Russie nouvelle ?
Mme Carrère d'Encausse,
parce que là,
c'est une vraie question.
-Non, je ne réponds pas.
-Mais sur cette question.
-Non, je ne m'engage pas
sur l'avenir.
-Mais là, ce n'est pas sur l'avenir.
Est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il est nécessaire
de nettoyer les écuries ?
-C'est aux Russes de le faire.
-Et de faire quoi ?
-Je pense que ça doit partir
de Russie. C'est ma conviction.
Il faut qu'il se passe
quelque chose.
-Qu'un tribunal en Russie
juge les crimes
de guerre ?
-Pour commencer,
il faut qu'il se passe
quelque chose. Et ça repose
sur la défaite militaire de Poutine.
Que son entourage ou je ne sais qui
se débarrasse de Poutine.
C'est la première chose. Après...
-Après, Laure Mandeville,
vous pensez qu'un tribunal
jugeant ses crimes de guerre,
c'est la condition
pour une Russie plus pacifiée ?
-Moi, je pense que
si l'on veut qu'émerge
une Russie démocratique,
ce que tout le monde souhaite,
mais qui, à mon avis,
est un pari énorme.
Je pense qu'il faut quand même,
avant de vous répondre,
dire qu'aujourd'hui,
la Russie est dans un abîme.
Ce qu'il faut,
si l'on veut sortir
de cet abîme,
et on veut aussi que l'Europe
devienne enfin un pays
qui soit délivré
du deuxième totalitarisme
du 20e siècle,
qui a continué au 21e.
Il faudra
un procès du communisme,
du poutinisme
et effectivement, une détota...
...une détotalitarisation
de la Russie.
-Le temps échu est passé.
-Sous quelles modalités,
c'est très dur à dire.
-Je voudrais l'avis
de l'ambassadeur.
Est-il nécessaire
de juger les crimes de guerre
par un tribunal international ?
-C'est essentiel.
C'est la raison pour laquelle
nous pensons et nous parlons
pour avoir un tribunal spécial
pour l'Ukraine,
pas juste le tribunal qui existe,
mais créer un tribunal spécial
pour juger toutes les choses.
Parce que la justice,
c'est la base après la guerre.
Ce n'est pas juste
la victoire de l'Ukraine,
mais comme Laure l'a dit,
la dépoutinisation de la société.
C'est très important.
-Alexandre Melnik,
sur l'Occident.
-L'Occident a déjà raté
le Nuremberg du communisme.
Il ne faut pas qu'on rate
le Nuremberg du poutinisme.
Donc, pour moi,
le tribunal international
avec l'implication
de l'ensemble de l'Occident,
y compris, évidemment,
les Etats-Unis,
c'est la condition sine qua non
de la sortie de cette situation
ubuesque et tragique
dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui.
C'est aussi la base d'une nouvelle
Russie démocratique, connectée
au monde, à la globalisation
du 21e siècle.
-On n'a plus de temps.
Un mot, Laure Mandeville,
là-dessus ?
-La grande question,
c'est quelles seront
les modalités
de ce procès dont nous parlons,
de cette justice
que nous voulons tous,
car elle nous paraît indispensable ?
Est-ce que ce sera avec un régime
qui émergera, si ça s'effondre ?
S'il perd la guerre,
le régime s'effondrera
et il y aura une volonté russe
de faire ce procès.
Ou est-ce que ce cela
se passera à l'extérieur ?
Là, c'est beaucoup
plus difficile de voir
comment ça pourra fonctionner.
Quand il y a eu Nuremberg,
il y avait une occupation
de l'Allemagne.
Là, on va buter sur quelque chose
de très compliqué à organiser
parce que la guerre n'a pas lieu
sur le territoire russe.
-Un mot là-dessus,
Mme Carrère d'Encausse ?
-Je pense que c'est aux Russes
de régler le problème.
-C'est à eux
de faire justice ?
-Absolument.
Je pense que pour qu'ils acceptent,
c'est à eux de le faire.
Je voudrais juste dire un mot.
La Russie ne se porte pas bien,
en ce moment.
Mais regardez la fuite des cerveaux
et véritablement,
la fuite de populations
qui s'est produite dans ce pays.
Elle est bien plus importante que
celle qui s'est produite après 1917.
Il y a un sursaut
de la partie la plus dynamique,
la plus vivante,
la plus intellectuelle du pays.
Cela a une signification
considérable.
-Merci, madame.
Merci, mesdames.
Merci, messieurs,
d'avoir participé
à cette émission.
Une brève bibliographie.
Laure Mandeville
a rappelé ce grand ouvrage
de Catherine Belton,
"Les hommes de Poutine".
On apprend tout sur le KGB
et sur les liens criminels
du KGB
dans lesquels
a plongé Vladimir Poutine.
Je voudrais
signaler, de Mme Carrère d'Encausse,
aux éditions Pluriel
"Alexandra Kollontaï,
"la valkyrie de la révolution",
personnage extrêmement intéressant.
Vous avez l'air d'être
très attachée à cette personne.
-C'est un personnage très séduisant,
un modèle pour notre époque,
d'une certaine façon.
C'est une féministe
comme on en trouve peu.
-Et c'est elle
qui a inventé
cette notion de finlandisation.
-Absolument. C'est elle
qui a réussi à sauver la Finlande,
à sauver par la neutralité
l'indépendance de la Finlande
alors qu'elle était
ambassadeur à ce moment-là.
Je dirais que
le concept a servi après.
-Très bien.
"Quand l'Ukraine se lève",
Constantin Sigov
et Laure Mandeville.
En un mot.
D'après vous, la naissance
de la nation ukrainienne,
elle est liée
à ce coup bas poutinien
ou ça existait avant ?
-Ca existait avant. Aujourd'hui,
c'est le moment où le miracle
de la résistance devient manifeste.
Mais en réalité,
la nation ukrainienne est en marche
depuis très longtemps
et nous ne l'avions pas mis
sur notre carte mentale.
C'est ce que
ce livre essaie de raconter.
-Je voudrais rappeler
également de Laure Mandeville
chez Grasset "La reconquête russe".
-C'était 2008,
mais ça annonçait
exactement ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui.
-En tout cas,
une drôle de reconquête.
Je voudrais rappeler,
d'Alexandre Melnik,
"Le monde nous appartient".
A quel monde
vous faites allusion ?
-Le monde global interconnecté,
interdépendant,
c'est-à-dire celui que
j'enseigne en géopolitique.
Le monde du 21e siècle.
La place de chaque individu
de notre planète,
quelle que soit sa couleur de peau.
La géolocalisation de ce monde.
-Merci.
Avant de vous quitter,
je voudrais vous laisser
avec cette pensée de Philip Roth.
qui vient en écho
de la fin de notre émission.
"Les procès des criminels de guerre
"lavaient la terre
de ses démons une fois pour toutes."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA